du musst auf so vieles achten heute Gendern
und kulturelle Aneignung und cancel culture
was ist politisch noch korrekt was ich gerade
nicht mehr korrekt ich habe im Sommer lernen
müssen dass ich mein Lieblingslied von
Eric Clapton nicht mehr hören darf Leila
euch das geht nicht da werde ich gleich
gebranntmarkt als geistiger Ballermann der
als Puffmutter im Festzelt sexuelle Ausbeutung
hilflose Frauen unterstützt meine Güte war das
eine gute okay es war Sommerloch und kein
Krokodil im Baggersee aber muss man deswegen
so einen schwach martensong wie Laila durch
ein mitgrillverbot in Festzelten bei uns erst
richtig interessantes das ist da so richtig
gepusht meine Güte wir haben doch früher bei
unseren kellerpartys auch gekrönt oder nee wir
waren ins Puff nach Barcelona ole ole das hat
das hat niemanden interessiert zu mal
wieder auch gar nicht hingefahren sind
wer darf heute noch was die finnische
Ministerpräsidentin sanna-marien die
hatten sie über den Sommer in der Mangel weil
sie auf einem Rockkonzert war und auf Partys
getanzt hat hallo sind die Konservativen
gleich da haben die gegeistert und hat
eine junge intelligente gut aussehende Frau
die trotz ihres Amtes auch noch Spaß hat
es geht ja gar nicht es müssen endlich wieder
die langweiligen alten grauen weißen Männer ran
die nach Mottenkugeln riechen nur so kann ein
Land anständig regiert werden und es mit der
kulturellen Aneignung das war ja schon lange vor
so das trachtenjanka Thema war eine deutsche weiße
Sängerin Ronja Malzahn mit Dreadlocks also
mit Raster locken also mit verfilztem Haar
wurde von einer Fridays for future Demo
ausgeladen weil haben gesagt Dreadlocks
ursprünglich aus dem afrikanischen
Kulturkreis kommen geht nicht haben
die Kiddies gemeint auftreten darfst Du bei
uns nur wenn du dir die Haare schneidest du
eine erwachsene verschiebt sich dann immer
gerade was uns wird früher immer gesagt du
gehst erst dann wieder aus dem Haus wenn du
die Haare ordentlich hast aber wie hätte es
funktionieren sollen also wie kommt man zum
Friseur wenn man nicht aus dem Haus darf
und ich war immer brav ich habe immer gefolgt
also an den Spätschäden leite ich heute noch
nein haben sie gesagt es geht nicht weil es
beleidigt und beschämt die dortigen Kulturvölker
die sich bestimmt wahnsinnig dafür interessiert
haben was auf einer Fridays for future Demo
in Hannover abgeht sind die haben ganz andere
Probleme als kulturell anderweitig angeeignete
locken so wird übrigens das hallo Dreadlocks
gab es schon bei den Wikingern den Kelten und
den alten Griechen wahrscheinlich wird es mit den
Sternsingen bei uns aber geändert nur die heiligen
drei Könige kommen künftig nur noch zu zweit weil
Melchior nur mit Black facing geht und wir in den
Grundschulen nicht genügend in die Gene schwarze
Weise aus dem Morgenland auftreiben können
kulturelle Aneignung und dann die Krönung
der Debatte weiß gerade im Urlaub Ende August
der Ravensburger Verlag hatte sein Buch der
Junge Häuptling Winnetou vom Markt genommen
indigene Gruppen könnten sich durch die stereotype
Darstellung verletzt fühlen das hat eigentlich
niemanden interessiert bis zwei Tage später Bild
und Welt eine riesen Welle draus gemacht haben
oh der Verlag sein die Knie gegangen weil eine
Minderheit ihren voten Wahnsinn mit Shitstorms
durchgesetzt hätte aber von der anderen Seite kam
der Shitstorm die von den gab gar keine die haben
sie ins linke wollen uns Winnetou nehmen ARD
zeigt keine Filme mehr stimmt aber schon länger
nicht mehr weil die rechte mit der Konstantin
Film ausgelaufen war aber egal der Boulevard
hatte mit der Stimmung gemacht und weiterhin
kräftig Klicks gesammelt ich habe die ganze
Aufregung sowieso nie verstanden Winnetou
also wir sind doch alle damit groß geworden
das Bild war doch die Indianer das
sind die edlen und die guten und
die Bleichgesichter das waren die Bösen
und die blöden wenn ich mich nicht irre
das war doch in Ordnung also und sehr realistisch
dargestellt das einzige was ich als Kind an den
bei den Verfilmungen nie verstanden habe war
wieso ein Franzose Häuptling der Apachen konnte
ja eine DDR Jugoslawen heute auch nicht
mehr sagen aber damals war es noch einer
also selber können wir bei
diesen Themen nicht mal ein
bisschen lockerer kann man das nicht
aber mit dem Augenzwinkern irgendwo
geht es nicht dass man da also ich wie gesagt
Ende August war ich im Urlaub in Kanada aber am
Fräser Lake und da ist meine Freundin gesagt
komm da oben hat sie eine Bar lass uns etwas
trinken gehen und dann sind wir dahin ging eine
völlig verhaute Bar und da saßen drei also ich
müsste jetzt sagen Vertreter indigener vom Stamme
nein ich sag wie es war das saßen drei waschechte
Indianer und an der Bar ausgeschenkt
hat ein Ende also ein kanadischer Hände
komm setzt euch zu uns immer hin und dann haben
wir ja geh mal zu dem Hindu und hole drei Bier
woher weißt du dass das ein
hindurch Alter das weiß ich
gar nicht aber du wirst doch nicht
glauben dass ich zu dem Indien sah
Indiens das sind wir und hat er gefragt ja wo
wir herkommen und so dann haben sie glauben
es sind ja so bei Frankfurt Germany
man sagt der AH Germany du alter Nazi
Alter du blöde rote Haut und einmal
angestoßen wird ein schöner Abend
also man kann das auch mal einfach
ein bisschen entspannt [Applaus]